und jetzt das heute journal
guten Abend aus Sicht der Koalition gibt
es eine gute Nachricht bei ihrem
Krisengipfel morgen im Kanzleramt gibt
es ein Streit Thema weniger das e-fuel
Drama ist vom Tisch nach dem heute ein
Kompromiss mit der Europäischen
Kommission gestrickt wurde wobei man das
in Brüssel ja mit geballter Faust in der
Tasche Tat die Verärgerung darüber wie
Deutschland bzw die FDP in letzter
Minute den ganzen eu-betrieb aufhielt
ist mindestens so groß wie die Freude
von Verkehrsminister Wissing die Frage
wird sein ob die Industrie überhaupt
Interesse daran hat reihenweise PKW zu
bauen die ausschließlich mit e-fuels
betankt werden können
Christiane hübscher berichtet
noch gibt es sie nur in Kleinstmengen
aus dem Labor die e-fius der deutsche
Verkehrsminister aber hat für sie das
verbrennerverbot in Brüssel erfolgreich
aufgeweicht wir wollten immer das
Neuzulassung von Fahrzeugen auch nach
2035 noch möglich sind wenn diese
Fahrzeuge nur mit synthetischen
Kraftstoffen e-fuels betankt werden
können jetzt haben wir das durchgesetzt
es ist wissings Sieg gegen die
EU-Kommission die heute nur knapp
mitteilt wir haben eine Einigung mit
Deutschland über die künftige Nutzung
von ifius in Autos diese synthetischen
Kraftstoffe sind zwar klimaneutral aber
längst nicht marktreif und wohl auch
künftig nur eine Nische für Schiffe und
Flugzeuge sagen Experten das ganze
Theater nützt in erster Linie der FDP IV
sind nichts weiter als Wahlkampf Klimbim
sie sind ineffizient und teuer sehr sehr
aufwendig herzustellen wir brauchen
dafür sehr viel Ökostrom sie haben im
PKW Bereich nicht zu suchen auch der
Kanzler begrüßt die Entscheidung heute
eher verhalten
s können eine Möglichkeit sein wie viele
davon Gebrauch machen und ob das
überhaupt
relevant wird das kann niemand sagen
Wissing ist überzeugt die Ausnahme sei
juristisch sicher doch in Brüssel gibt
es Zweifel der Kompromiss ist nicht
rechtssicher bedauerlicherweise viele
Europaabgeordnete ich nicht aber andere
werden klagen und sie haben juristisch
gute Argumente
vorerst aber ist es das Ende einer
Blockade am Dienstag soll das Verbrenner
aus von der EU verabschiedet werden mit
der Ausnahme für e-fius
die Treibhausgase herunterzufahren um
die Erderwärmung abzubremsen ist das
eine zugleich aber muss sich die
Menschheit damit befassen wie sie die
Folgen des bereits eingetretenen
Klimawandels handelt darum ging es bei
der internationalen wasserkonferenz der
Vereinten Nationen was früher nur ferne
Länder vor allem auf der südlichen
Halbkugel zu betreffen schien ist ja
längst auch in Europa sichtbare Realität
Flüsse die nicht genug Wasser führen
Grundwasserspiegel die sinken trockene
Böden die nicht mehr die gewohnte Ernte
hervorbringen und wenn zwischendurch
extremer starkregenfeld hilft das auch
nicht im Gegenteil Johannes
es ist die Grundlage ein Lebens auf
unserem Planeten sauberes Wasser hier in
Chile am Fuße der Anden
doch sauberes Wasser ist zu einer
knappen Ressource geworden mehr als 2
Milliarden Menschen haben keinen
gesicherten Zugang es drohen
Verteilungskämpfe Massenmigration
wirtschaftliches Desaster und
Wasserknappheit ist längst kein Problem
des armen Südens mehr Bilder vom Rhein
im vergangenen Sommer
wir haben die Nachrichten das in Italien
und Frankreich durch eine Winter Dürre
sowohl die Wasserversorgung als auch die
Versorgung der Atomkraftwerke in
Frankreich problematisch ist und die
Alpengletscher immer stärker schmelzen
so dass wir auch in Deutschland in
Europa uns für nachhaltiges Management
den Schutz unserer unseres höchsten
Gutes des Wassers stärker engagieren
müssen drei Tage haben hier in New York
die Vereinten Nationen gemeinsam mit
mehr als 6000 Vertretern von NGOs und
Unternehmen beraten herausgekommen sind
gut 700 freiwillige
Selbstverpflichtungen für eine
nachhaltige Wasserwirtschaft es war
wirklich wie eine Auftaktveranstaltung
so fühlte sich das anders man kommt
zusammen man wirft mal alles auf dem
Tisch und jetzt muss es weitergehen aber
ich glaube schon dass durch die
Konferenz ein Signal noch mal raus
gesendet worden ist und diesen Impuls
müssen wir jetzt nutzen ein
wasserbeauftragter soll in Zukunft die
Maßnahmen koordinieren und in zwei
Jahren soll es eine Folge Konferenz
geben
Zeit drängt denn bis 2030 so die UNO
wird der weltweite Trinkwasserbedarf 40%
über dem vorhandenen Angebot liegen
das für den Klimaschutz mehr getan
werden muss findet in der Regel in der
Mehrheit der Bevölkerung große
Zustimmung etwas anders sieht es
allerdings aus wenn es dann um konkrete
Maßnahmen geht Windkraft super aber ein
Windrad vor meiner Haustür bitte nicht
auch die aktuelle Debatte über Gas und
Ölheizungen bildet dieses Dilemma ja ab
insofern kann man gespannt sein wie die
Berliner morgen bei ihrem Volksentscheid
für Klimaneutralität abstimmen ob die
Stadt bereits 2030 vollständig
klimaneutral sein soll der Berliner
Senats sagt das Ziel sei zwar richtig
aber so schnell realistisch nicht zu
schaffen aus Berlin Stefan Merseburger
[Musik]
konzertreiben mit politischer Botschaft
bis 2030 soll Berlin per Gesetz dazu
verpflichtet werden klimaneutral zu sein
so wollen es die Initiatoren des Volks
Entscheidens 70 Prozent der Missionen
entstehen in den Städten werden in den
Städten verursacht von daher muss die
Klimawende in den Städten anfangen das
würde bedeuten weitgehend der Verzicht
auf ölgas und Kohle in Kraftwerken
Umstellung auf erneuerbare Energien mehr
Solaranlagen und Wärmedämmung nur noch
E-Autos in der City für die
wahrscheinlich demnächst regierende
schwarz-rote Koalition ist das Ziel
utopisch es ist nicht möglich dass
Berlin bis 2030 klimaneutral sind das
muss man den Leuten auch klipp und klar
erklären alles andere ist Augenwischerei
von mir ein klares Votum nein zum Thema
Volksentscheid dann das würde viele
viele Probleme für Berlin bringen gerade
was Bezahlbarkeit angeht
geschätzte kosten etwa 100 Milliarden
Euro die Wissenschaft ist gespalten
nicht zu verwirklichen sagen die eine
wichtig die anderen also was
unrealistisch ist ist mit dem Business
das heißt weiterzumachen es geht nicht
ja also es wird ein Klima also der
Klimawandel ist jetzt schon sichtbar es
wird noch wärmer werden
klimaversprechen zumal gebrochene helfen
nicht weiter so die in Berlin
versammelten die Zeit die Welt zu retten
laufe davon
[Musik]
zum ersten Mal ist ein deutscher
katholischer Bischof wegen seiner Rolle
im Missbrauchskandal zurückgetreten
damit beginnen jetzt bei dir die
Nachrichten halt ja der Papst hat einen
Rücktritt gesucht des Osnabrücker
Bischofs Bode entsprochen wurde nannte
als einen Grund für seinen gesucht den
im September veröffentlichten
Zwischenbericht zur aufbearbeitung
sexualisierte Gewalt im Bistum Osnabrück
diese habe ihm noch einmal deutlich
seine eigenen Fehler im Umgang mit
Missbrauchsfällen vor Augen geführt
russlands Präsident Putin hat die
Stationierung taktischer Atomwaffen in
der ehemaligen sowie Republik Belarus
angekündigt Putin sagte am Abend in
russischen Fernsehen darauf hätten sich
Moskau und Minsk geeinigt er verwies
dabei auf die Stationierung von
Atomwaffen der USA auf dem Gebiet von
deren Verbündeten in Europa
rund zweieinhalb Wochen nach dem
Amoklauf bei einer Gemeindeversammlung
der Zeugen Jehovas in Hamburg haben
tausende Mitglieder der
Glaubensgemeinschaft der Opfer gedacht
auch Vertreter aus Politik und Behörden
Namen teil bei dem Amoklauf hat er ein
35-jähriger sieben Menschen erschossen
und dann auch sich selbst
[Musik]
in der Warnstreik Aufrufe für Montag
verzichten mehrere Bundesländer Morgen
darauf dass Sonntagsfahrverbot für
Lastwagen durchzusetzen so können
Warentransporte gegebenenfalls
vorgezogen werden schon heute gab es in
Berlin eine Demonstration für die
Tarifforderungen der Gewerkschaften
Verdi und EVG außerdem ging es um
sozialgerechte Energiepreise und
bezahlbare Mieten
die Lottozahlen dieses samstags sie
lauten wie immer ohne Gewähr 10 15 16 21
35 36 Superzahl 5 und weitere
Gewinnzahlen finden sie auf
lotto.zdf.de und im zdf-
es ist wieder Zeit die Uhren umzustellen
eine Stunde nach vorne in dieser Nacht
von zwei auf drei Uhr dann ist
Sommerzeit auch wenn die
Wetteraussichten nicht danach klingen
morgen im Norden freundlich in der Mitte
teils länger anhaltender Regen und im
Süden wechseln bewölkt mit Schauern und
Gewittern sowie stürmischen Böen 7 bis
14 Grad am Montag bei 2 bis 9 Grad viele
Schnee und Schnee Regenschauer am
Dienstag vor allem von der Nordsee bis
ins östliche Bayern Regen und Schnee
Mittwoch wieder milder aber wechselhaft
mit der zweiten Halbzeit und die nächste
heute Express gibt es dann um 23 Uhr auf
Wiedersehen
[Musik]